the Joe Rogan experience well brian is
one of the best of that he's so silly
like most of his podcast that he does
yeah then with me and him out pretty
cool podcast we've known each other
forever we've been best friends since
1994 is that right yeah I mean cuz that
guy's smart I love him so much that I
broke up with this girl and Brian she
was she was calling me because she was
horny and I was like look I have a new
girlfriend but I have a friend [ __ ] you
and he's just like me high six Brian on
my ex girlfriend and he [ __ ] her one
of the funniest conversations I ever had
with an ex-girlfriend she calls me up
she goes your friend came inside me and
I went what she goes yeah your [ __ ]
friend came inside me and I was like
well did you tell him that you're on the
pill she goes no no I'm not on the pill
and I was like well I don't know what to
tell you you know that's Brian you guys
should have worked that out girlfriend
call you up mad because your friend
ejaculated inside of her it was one of
them well I hung up the phone I
literally fell to the ground laughing I
was lying on my back on the floor my
house look like it's just so ridiculous
as Brian Cowen Frank House everybody
so I called him up I said Jim what
happened and he's like whoops it was
just such a ridiculous conversation but
I've been friends with a guy forever so
all of our conversations are like that I
said all of our conversations are like
jokes and hazing and [ __ ] on each
other but it's all hugs and love I mean
I'm so positive and generous and you
know one funny thing I was looking at
his Instagram and he's seated next to I
know it can't remember was it cheetah
it's a wild cheetah in effort yeah and
he's talking about how he who's nice
with it
I like to get up in the morning perhaps
we will hunt together
I smell antelope nearby just like he's
cloudy there's a real cheetah yeah but
the cheetahs are interesting then you
can actually pet them
it's weird I think there's like it was a
game reserve I see like one of those
like Safari no no no yeah a lot of that
is in Africa not in terms of like like
there they're not pets yeah but they're
so used to people because people always
go on safari there and apparently you
can get real close to them in some
environments but cheetahs in particular
a lot of people keep them as pets like
you see like a lot of sheiks like rich
guys in the Middle East they'll be
driving around and they're [ __ ] AMG
wagons with a cheetah next to them cheat
on a leash and the Cheetahs just cool
with it see nobody nobody nobody is that
with hippos I think if you wanted to go
next level yeah that wouldn't work out
hippos just decided to [ __ ] you up yeah
what is with us in the hippos hippos are
like they're our cousin two pigs and
there's a right yeah they're a ruthless
[ __ ] animal oh now I see it
they don't play any games yeah yeah and
for vegetarians it's not even like that
we're their food they are vegetarians
but do you eat meat I know the kid well
sewed up deer
you know deer and cows they'll eat birds
we're not going back into that vampire
deer thing there no no freaked me out
last time
but deer oftentimes eat birds the ground
nesting birds there's a lot of video of
it like people don't want to believe it
they think that you know they just eat
grass that's most of the time they do
but they will eat a bird if they get a
chance you know
they know it's food yeah it's weird
yeah and they have an herbivores
digestive tract but no can still eat a
bird there's a lot of video well idea I
guess I've been really fascinated by the
number of species in which some human
like totally deadly species where some
human has decided I'm gonna dedicate my
life to hanging out and not getting
eaten hyenas there's some [ __ ] that
is mean he's hanging out with hyenas on
the internet and petting them they seem
really playful and friendly real sweet
it's real weird
this guy's like nuzzling these hyenas
imagine choosing hi Nia that's your
system
that is a that is an animal that bites
so [ __ ] hard they have they have like
one of the strongest bites ever measured
because they're their whole thing is
just smashing bones and trying to get
out the nutrition that the Lions leave
behind so they're all just about
crushing bones so they're their whole
face is designed to smash bones yeah and
you know they're their [ __ ] roots see
here's the guy he's hanging out with his
hyenas he plays with them look at this
[ __ ] but say they're playing with
them they're yeah they seem to think
he's like their buddy look they're all
they're biting him but they're gentle I
mean they could rip his arm clean off
but they're biting its leg and you know
he's nuzzling with them it's lady read
his face I do not know I do not know
because I think a lot of these have to
do with him pretty oh yeah for sure yeah
well that was the thing with my friend
Phil DeMars who worked at Marineland one
of the reasons why he's so furious at
that misguide a walrus named smooshing
and the walrus imprinted with him when
it was really young walrus thinks that's
his mom okay that he's rather the walrus
his mom you know so he's just on this
[ __ ] furious quest to get this walrus
released and to shut down this [ __ ]
known as marine land yeah he's been sued
forever he's been involved in lawsuits
as long as I've known them and he's been
coming on this podcast for years
for years we've been you know trying to
boost his signal and trying to get the
word out and then when blackfish came
out that sort of really turned the tide
right where people got a chance to see
what Orca captivity is really like and
they're like holy Sh this is horrific
it is absolutely barbaric
[Applause]